all right Mercedes
Mercedes where'd you grow up where are
you from originally originally I'm from
Thomasville North Carolina Smalls
it's like everybody knows everybody
cousins you grew up with your parents
um I actually grew up with my grandma
and my auntie and my grandpa
um my mama she actually went to jail
when I was about
maybe five
what you go to jail for
um
um I want to say but um she went to jail
for maybe about six years or so
then she came back home I want to say I
was
into Middle School at that point
how would you describe your childhood in
general
what size not having my mom around for
six years my childhood was pretty good
um I made pretty good grades in school
we went on family trips all the time
um I left a good childhood
nothing traumatizing your father is out
of the picture
oh no my father's in the future yes yeah
um women that whenever my mother went to
jail he was still around
he's still around today
um we're in like we're not as close as
we should be but
just call it when I need some money
I've heard you in school
um I did some college so I actually went
to college in Raleigh North Carolina
um Shaw University it's a private school
um
I did freshman year did my sophomore
year
um got up to my junior year
um got a boyfriend
which was a bad idea
so whenever I got a boyfriend I like
stopped going to class
I stopped just being in Raleigh in
general I would just be back at home
So eventually I ended up dropping out of
college about six months later
is uh well
reverse a little bit whenever I dropped
out of college I worked a little bit I
tried to get a job
um but when I whenever I was in school a
little bit
um Shaw University
College was kind of hard but it was easy
but it was hard I say it was hard
financially because everybody had money
to do stuff and I really didn't have
money to do anything so
I decided that I wanted to make some
money when I was in college or whatever
this is before I dropped out
had to ride a little bit so
whenever I was in college for a little
bit I decided to get on this website
called seeking arrangement
so I met me like a sugar daddy or I
thought I did
um it was very very very bad so
um that was my first attempt in college
so did my my first attempt then my
second attempt uh same website secret
Arrangement so I met this guy
um he was a great great guy
um
and he really did take care of me he
paid my tuition he did everything like
um he was just great but I still ended
up dropping out of school even though he
did all of that for me I did have a
boyfriend at the time and it's just like
I don't know I just went with my
boyfriend is Big so
um with having a sugar daddy I didn't
have sex with him or anything like that
so I just thought it was okay to still
have a boyfriend but that was really
wrong but
um I did still have a boyfriend and a
sugar daddy so
like I was saying sugar daddy was paying
for your college tuition and other
things too probably yeah but there was
no sex involved no
so and that was another fishy thing I
don't know why he didn't want sex but
um so I ended up dropping out of school
or whatever so
six months later I was working or
whatever I was working at a call center
I was making good money
um
me and my friend we worked there
together we were commuting really really
good friend like kind of like my best
friend I caught her sister
so we were working or whatever
so one Friday she's like my friends
having a party we should go
so I'm like okay so we go to the party
or whatever it's late it's probably like
12 a.m We go to a stripper party we're
just drinking doing all type of drugs I
was like all type of drugs but just
doing drugs drinking stuff like that so
um when it came down to it
that night I ended up getting shot I
don't want to go into details about it
but I ended up getting shot
um it was on accident and I want to say
the friend that I went there with I
don't want to blame her but she played a
big part in me getting shot and I want
to say like the messed up part about it
all like she never even came to the
hospital to see me like even after I got
shot she never came one time to see me
and even like the other girls that I was
with
they never came so
um after I got shot I stayed in the
hospital for about a month after that
month was up they asked me that I want
to go to physical therapy I was in very
very critical condition
um I wasn't able to walk
um
I couldn't bathe myself I couldn't do a
lot of things like I had to learn how to
do everything over again so I said yes
to physical therapy I did that got
myself back together
I want to say it took eight months all
together for me to start that walking
just to get back to my normal self and I
also did have a colostomy bag
which is I call it a [__] bag it was
like right here so
um I got that reversed a year later that
was good
um anybody who has a colostomy bag I
really really really do respect you
because that's a lot to deal with
um
just having a colostomy bag in general
like I don't know what I would do if I
had a colostomy back
um to this day so
um
after I ended up getting myself back
together and got my colossian bag
reversed you know I was feeling back to
myself I wasn't as depressed anymore
um because before then
like those whole eight months I was
depressed I was wanting to kill myself
just things like that I wasn't wanting
to live anymore I just wasn't happy so
after I started that walking and things
like that I just you know got my groove
back my motivation so
I was just happy again so I don't know
why the same girls that didn't come see
me in the hospital
I ended up going back to go with them I
don't know why but I don't know so I
ended up chilling back with them which
was dumb of me because why would you
even go chill with some girls that
didn't even come to you in the hospital
so I did that
she was basically telling me like she
was having like money problems just that
third I'm just like well you know I
don't have a job right now I've been out
of work I was in the hospital and been
out of work that whole year and then I
got my colossian reverse I've been out
of work for eight months so it's damn
near two years so I'm like what you
trying to do so she
trying to act like she don't go she's
like well I got this phone and I think
that the girl who used to own this phone
I think she used to be a prostitute
because it's some text messages in there
so I'm just like what so I'm like all
right let me see like what kind of text
messages this is like what you talking
about
so I read the text messages or whatever
between her and the person and she's
basically
she's whoever texting back and forth
with other people they're basically
oh how much where any call out call
things like that so I'm just reading it
or whatever just like trying to like
catch on to like the language and like
what they're talking about like what
this like what does what means so
um after the already all the text
messages or whatever she's like so what
you trying to do so I'm all right so I
was like we can go half in the room so
we go half on the room mind you we
haven't even created no account or no
profile or we don't even know the
websites that the the processes Beyond
we don't know nothing so
I'm like all right we still gonna try
anyways the room cheap as hell we gonna
give it a go so
we end up getting a room or whatever so
tell me why we end up getting a room
it's the same girl that I was with when
I got shot so we ended up getting the
room or whatever
it was like I want to say it was like 8
P.M when we got the room so it's still
early as hell so tell me why
we didn't have one person pull up like
we didn't have one customer like we had
zero like I kind of felt so bad because
I'm like dang we got to be like the
roast the worst prostitutes in the world
like this is our first day and like we
like I don't know if it's her first day
but it's my first day and like we made
zero dollars like can we at least make
the room money back so
by this time it's like 3 A.M so I'm like
damn like
we really ain't
so I ended up just texting one of the
um one of the guys that I was [__] at
the time just to come over gave me some
money
so I'm just like digging in my head like
well dang maybe it is not for me or
maybe I'm one about it the wrong way so
all right so again so I try to link up
with my other um girl
we do the same thing go half on the room
but it's like maybe some months later
like I'm still out of work because I'm
healing for my event shot wound like I
can't really get a job because I can't
stand up for long I can't really walk
I just can't do nothing that I'll be
able to do a job that I would normally
be able to do so I was just trying any
and everything so
I go with her or whatever
um we get a room
same little thing it's early as hell
um but this time it was good because uh
we had uh somebody actually came
but it wasn't for me it was for her but
I was still happy as [__] because I'm
like I don't know how I work like I
still haven't experienced it yet like
is this how it's gonna be like what the
[__] is going on
so mind you the home credit on with now
she know all the websites she know all
tricks she just know everything like she
she know everything so
she got her little first player whatever
so I'm happy as hell I'm like oh yeah
I'm like oh yeah it's lit now so mind
you I still ain't even got no date or
whatever so I'm like oh yeah
so as time gone it's like dang I still
haven't got no date yet like how does
this work like what's going on like what
am I doing wrong
so
the whole time like I don't even got no
I don't have no I got a phone but I
don't know the website I don't know if
she really posted me or not like is she
just getting like she had two plays and
all that's it but it's like I'm like I
got zero text messages and I'm just
depending on her so I'm just like I
don't know [__] that so
I was just like all right whatever cool
so but it's like she's so into the game
like
she's someone to the game that like she
every place she's still gonna break you
off like
like after every play she still gave me
some money like I didn't do nothing
or nothing she just still broke me off
because I guess that's part of the game
I don't know but
um but it's like dang like
I feel like she wasn't posting me
because why did I not have one play so I
was kind of disappointed and I'm like
dang I can't get no real job
I can't even see a coochie right like
what's going on so I'm like all right
well let me go back to what I was doing
in college I was like let me try to find
me a little friend because the friend
that I had here in Raleigh but
I'm still kind of [__] up from The
Gunshot accident so I'm like I really
can't get back and forth to Riley like I
want to
somewhere let me go back on the website
so I finally meet somebody or whatever
so real nice dude on his own company or
whatever
um treat me right pay my rent
um just do everything right whatever
um so I started talking to him I want to
say in 2021
um I still talk to him now I have
started talking to other people to
um I want to say you know I probably got
like two sugar daddies and then
I might
I might have like three four Dudes trick
on me every now and then like whenever
I'm bored
um but like as far as like
um
I'm gonna say as far as me
getting shot and then I didn't have a
job and things like that
so I went ahead and got a sugar daddy
again because that was my only result
so in between this I started back taking
perks because I had a my colossian
reversal so the doctor prescribed me
some perks for my colossian reversal so
I didn't I took perks like whenever I
had my first gunshot accident in like
2019 but I stopped just fine like it was
fine
so like when I got my collection
reversal it's like I was like I just
kept taking the perks just kept taking
them every day every day every day
so
um I noticed that I had a problem
whenever
like I didn't have a prescription
anymore but I was still taking them
somehow not somehow but some have so
um I know I had a problem then but I
didn't tell anybody I just kept taking
them like trying to find them on the
street somehow
so
um
I I want to say I taken the perk
every day
for the last four years because I got
shot in 2019
so I taken the perk every day since then
I'm not gonna say one like probably up
to like 80 milligrams a day like I take
perk 10 so
probably about eight pills a day
um
I tried to stop
um kind of hard to stop taking the perks
or whatever
um one time it got so bad
that I went to the hospital for help
because I didn't want to like go to my
mama or like my grandpa or anybody
I didn't want anybody to judge me or
anything so I went to the hospital so
um
with me going to the hospital like
basically telling them like I'm addicted
to perks
um like I think I'm addicted to it
because of my gunshot accident like I
just started taking them every day every
day every day
and I'm just like basically crying like
I'm telling them like I'm addicted to
perks I need help like I don't want to
do this anymore
so
um
these [__] they put me uh like
normally you just have like one of those
gowns because I go to the hospital all
the time because I have stomach problems
so usually they just put you in the Gown
or whatever everything's fine so they
dressed me out in like this little
outfit it was like a pants and shirt so
I'm like oh my God I'm about to go to
the crazy house so
um I talked to the nurse on the screen
or whatever so I'm basically crying like
I'm telling her like
I'm telling her what's going on like I'm
addicted to perks like
um I haven't been fine since my accident
um like I come to the hospital every
other month like to see what's wrong
with me and like y'all say the same
thing like oh it's just gastronitis or
you have to take your acid medicine and
stuff like that
so
I was basically just crying like I need
help I want help so
these [__] they gave me a shock
morphine so I'm just like I'm like
literally begging for help and y'all
give me a shot of morphine so but it's
like deep down inside I was happy as
[__] so I just shut up I just stopped
crying and I went to sleep so they
probably released me from the hospital I
want to say that later on that morning
like 8 A.M something like that
so but before they released me it's like
one Doctor Who came in who time to know
my situation and I've been shocked for
and he kind of like prayed over me he
kind of read my foul like you're coming
in here saying that you want help and he
was like the first sign of recovery is
admitting that you have a problem
he said like you're coming here
admitting that you need help that you
want help and they gave you a shot of
morphine
so I was
after that I was kind of disappointed
because I'm like well if they don't give
a [__] I damn sure don't go [__] so
when I went home about perks so
um this was probably I want to say about
six months ago when I first did that
um tried to get help
um
that happened and then
second time I tried to get help but this
time I went to a family member it's a
this time I went to a family member
I was telling her like I was feeling
hurt basically like what I was born
through and she just offered to buy me
some perks which is like I'm still be
where I'm going through like I'm not
telling you what I'm going through so
you could buy me some perks I'm telling
you what I'm going through so you can
get me help or like help me or just
listen to me
so
would you know me I'm high already so
I just took money to get to perk so I
went to go to get some perks oh
I won't say what it feels but
it was really like it was really close
to me yeah I really didn't expect that
like she probably honestly thought that
I was asking for money or something but
I honestly wasn't like I just wanted her
to listen
so
um I ended up just buying perks that day
well I was already high so about more
perks got high as [__]
um
it's just like I want to get help
bad but
I don't know how I don't know where I
need to start
um
it's like
it's like I got addicted because the
doctors were helping me but it's like
who's gonna help me now because I damn
sure don't want to get help from them
like they can't be morphine when I went
for help hey that's not help
but
um I started talking to my mom about it
some more
and she started like finding programs
and stuff like inpatient programs so I'm
gonna do that a little bit
um the inpatient programs
um
because I know if I stay at home and try
to do it then I'm just gonna take a perk
again
um but if I like go somewhere for
impatient then like I can stay there I
won't be able to like it's in Greensboro
though but I won't be able to go home
like I won't be able to go to the
apartment
um like I just won't be around all of
that so
um I said I was gonna go before the
summer
um I do work now
um
it's like before then
um it got real bad because
before I had found a job whatever like
it was my first job in three years since
I got shot so
I was happy
but it's like
I was the manager so I had too much
power so
um like on my breaks I leave like the
job was already 45 minutes itself so
your break is only what 30 minutes to an
hour
so every day I would leave like I don't
care I'm leaving I'm the manager
nobody's here like I'm the only one here
every day so I leave so I go get me some
perks come back be housework at work
and then it got so bad to the point
where I was leaving every day and so I
would get caught though like it would be
so stupid because I would get caught
so I ended up getting fired or whatever
so all do you know I'm 26. I got shot
when I was 22.
um my birthday is January 24th
um I got shot March the 19th in 2019 I
was 22.
um
so then today you're still you're still
using Percocets yeah unfortunately
um imma try to do
um it's getting real bad because when I
ended up getting fired now I can see
myself going down the same path again
that's why I'm trying to get help like
um every day for lunch I'll leave go
give me a Percocet
um
but this time like I'll return to work
like in my two hours first time at work
like I just be out but this time like
I'll return to work like I just needed
I just needed to complete my date like
my day is so much better like if I have
my Percocet and a blunt I think it's
great like no problems no nothing and I
keep on saying purchase it but I
probably popped two at a time like two
two cartons I buy them two at a time
probably four or five hours apart but
like now that I'm at work I probably pop
them during lunch and then when I get
off before I go to bed but it's like I
don't want to do that when I'm on lunch
because I see myself going down the same
path like soon I'll do it on lunch I'm
not gonna return back to work like so
I've been trying to get clean
um hopefully I'm gonna do the inpatient
program soon I say before the summer
time
so hopefully next month is May so I'll
be there even mayor June
um
and you're not doing sex work anymore
huh you're doing sex work still
yeah I have a sugar daddy you do yeah um
I just feel like
I always go have a sugar daddy
like
nobody really wants to have a job like I
feel like
we work eight hours into the day
to make a hundred dollars
I can make
I can make twice three times four times
that amount
in an hour like that's nothing
so
um
I do I do have a sugar daddy I was
depending on him full time before I got
a job like I was depending strictly on
him like he was paying my rent he would
Supply my habit like he was basically
doing everything but it's like
I got to the point where
I'm picky so like
even though even if I was down to my
last like I never get on the website and
post my ad and be like yeah like I'm
about to go do this like it has to be
like I'm real picky like I have to pick
the person like they can't pick me like
ain't no picking me you got to get
picked so it was kind of tough for me on
that end so like that's why I try to
deal with the same person every time
like that's why I had the same rotation
the same group of [__] they just in
rotation
but um yeah he pays my rent
um I really just got a job
like just to have money because like
like that that adds up like my rent like
me going shopping my addiction stuff
like that I know that adds up so like he
just be dried up by then so that's when
my job comes in and I just do whatever
those checks but deep down inside like I
don't need that job like that job just
for fun that job is to help me not take
a perk every hour like I have something
to do like it makes me feel like I have
something to do with my life like but I
hate work like I don't want to be there
what's your long-term goal to get it
some other job that you are
into or or just be somebody's sugar baby
um
I do want to have a lot of a long time
job like I'm into like interior design
graphic design anything to make
something look better like that's what
I'm into
um but it's like you have to go back to
school for stuff like that and it's like
I'm just so old now like it's like I was
I was recovering from that gush hot
wound like for four years now and it's
like life just passed me by like I'm
just stuck in the same spot I'm still
stuck in 2019 and everybody else in 2023
like I don't know
that's weird emotionally what do you go
through now
um emotionally I'm depressed uh actually
I like everything's okay
I don't know I just keep everything to
myself like even my close friends
they don't know me like they probably
wait in on this video to drop like
like oh my God I just want to hear about
Luke's life like oh my God I said like
but I just want to hear about Alex life
um like stuff like that because I don't
I'm not
I'm a talkative person but I don't
really
I don't really
I ain't gonna say I don't really tell my
business but like
you keep certain things to yourself
so it's like
they just be confused so like they
probably waiting right now like dang
what is she gonna say like you don't
look like a drug addict
that's the craziest thing like it is so
crazy because one thing that makes me
mad is because
people would be like
when I tell them like I got a problem
they were like oh well you got shot
so like I have a problem dude like do
y'all hear me like
I said I have a problem they're like
well you you you're in pain still like
okay but like it's different ways to
cook with your pain I'm sure like you
don't gotta pop a pill to cope with your
pain but I do
what's your biggest regret what do you
wish you had done differently in your
life
oh
my biggest regret
is hanging out with uh like friends that
I shouldn't have been hanging out with
[Music]
um
like you'll see all the signs like stop
hanging out with that person or like
stop being with that group of people
like you ignore all those signs and
still
hang with those people but like I'm I'm
really not easily influenced at all like
I'm not influ like I'm not easily
influenced but when it comes down to it
when you hang with those group of people
like eventually like you are like
you're gonna just like them you're gonna
do the same stuff they're doing like
you're just gonna you're gonna fall with
them like
you could say birds of a feather don't
flock together but eventually they're
gonna flock together like
um
it's weird
what's your biggest fear now my biggest
fear
it might sound crazy but um
my biggest fear is dying alone I only
about to die by myself like
which I know I'm gonna doubt with myself
because everybody got a dollar theyself
but
I know I'm scared of dying alone I'm
scared to be about myself like
um you're a little young to be worried
about dying
from like the part of town that I'm from
the city that I'm from the area that I'm
from people die every day like young
people and it'd be over stuff that don't
even have anything to do with them like
you're just dead
just being a sugar baby get in the way
of your love life
me honestly it's like whenever I had
that uh boyfriend in college like he
killed everything like
I blame everything on him like I blame
the reason why I dropped out of school
on him like I blame me getting shot on
him because if I was at school I would
have never been out there with them Hood
alone
you don't take responsibility for any of
that stuff no
I could have okay yeah okay
yeah you're the one that said yes
okay I do take responsibility sometimes
but it's like but after him like I don't
I don't I
it's hard to deal with a guy like
uh guys are just ugh it's like they all
want one thing
so I always think [__]
and it seemed like I would say my ex but
like even after him like all the guys
after him they all want one thing they
all trying to do one thing so hey why
not give me some money
is that the mentality in the hood that
what a woman
can offer sexually is is basically
something to trade for what a
major offer financially
like this go way back like yo granny
yeah not your granny but
they granny
they grannies used to give it up to pay
that rent like stop playing yeah just go
way back
Mercedes what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
you're not out of the woods yet but
I'm sure you're learning things
the most important listing
it's crazy because even though I've been
through all of this
I still haven't learned to listen
like
[Music]
I feel like I am the lesson like I don't
know like I still have not learned to
listen yet at all you're young yet
you're in the middle of your
tornado yeah that's what it feels like
I think you
seem to have the desire to figure out a
way a way out
you seem like a smart girl you'll figure
something out
it's like I don't know
add in today's like I want to try and
change but I know it'll be hard like
I've been doing this for a while now
like
like oh wow like I don't I don't really
see myself changing like even when I get
older like but what's the difference
though like me depending on like my
sugar daddy and then like you depending
on like not you I keep on seeing you but
damn
um like what's the difference between me
depending on my sugar daddy and you
depending on your husband like it's the
same thing like we just not married it's
the same thing he take care of you and
he take care of me like it's the same
thing
that different is it no
no same thing
but like people try to make it seem like
my sister she actually calls me a
prostitute I don't correct her or
anything like that like I think it's all
the same like if you
do any type of sex work like
you could call me a hooker or a positive
a hoe a [__] I don't know like you call
me any name in the book I just feel like
it's all the same thing like I don't
really put titles on it so whenever she
tell my my family like yeah she's a
prostitute like I don't correct her
because like in the way it's all the
same thing like um
I'm one I'm wanting something in return
just like a prostitute like when I like
it may not be the same type of way like
I might not get the funds up front or he
might not lay the money on the counter
in that type of way but I want that
money like I want that money
it's it's the same thing to me it's hard
for a young girl to make enough money to
do all the things you want to do yeah
like um everything's expensive and then
you know like
like just need money maybe we should
finish college
yeah and stayed in college
I wish I uh like never had a boyfriend I
wish I like stay focused
um
I always say like just being around
people in general like having a
boyfriend having friends
which Mark told me to take
accountability but
I feel like all of that really like just
sent me spiraling like because I was in
college I was doing good you guys hooked
up with the wrong kind of friends and
the wrong kind of guys
I was in Raleigh and they were back at
home like why not stay in Raleigh why
are you going all the way back home like
to be with them it just didn't make
sense to me
but y'all
you're smart girl you'll figure it out
hopefully I hope I hope I'm trying to
figure it out
um like I said the first step to
recovery is admitting that you have a
problem
um I've already admitted that I have a
problem it takes a lot of courage to
come up here and do this yeah so my next
step is going to be getting help
um
yeah
I wish you all the luck in the world
thank you you're still young
doesn't feel like you I feel like I'm
30.
you got a feeling you're gonna figure it
out I hope so
I hope so like I feel like this world
has so much to offer and then like when
I'm on those Percocets I'm just stuck in
that one spot like
Tom is going but I'm still waiting do
you feel like you deserve a better life
better things out of life than you're
getting with this current situation
you're in
like I deserve yeah what do you deserve
I'm gonna say I deserve like if I
deserved it I would have it have I
worked for it to deserve it no
but when I work for it then yeah I might
deserve it but I haven't worked for
anything
but I love working for stuff like I
don't like handouts
maybe that's the problem what that
you're not really putting in the effort
yeah but like I said it's also the perks
so it's like I just be so high I just
I smoke and go to sleep yeah it's hard
to apply yourself towards anything when
you're high like that yeah
just go to sleep
but I do feel like
I feel like if I put in the work and
effort then
yeah I definitely don't want to be at
the customer service dog for too much
longer but
um I
I know that whenever I go to like rehab
or whatever I'm probably gonna quit that
job just because just to get myself
together just focus on me and then after
I get out of rehab then
whole new start whole new reset and I'm
gonna go from there
[Applause]
with everything thank you